- I'm Jordan Klepper
at the Opposition
and I know you've
seen this today.
Dick's Sporting Goods
has caved to the liberals
and will no longer
carry assault weapons
or sell guns to people under 21.
You hear that?
Dick's has gone soft.
It used to be a rock hard
second amendment ally
and, now, they expect us to
just play with their balls
and other sporting equipment.
No way!
And yet, there stock is up
and has been up for
more than four hours.
They should call someone.
Those pricks, I'm furious!
Now that Dick's is
no longer cocked
they might as well
be firing blanks.
And they're not alone,
all of these companies
have also shafted gun owners
and paved the way for
Dick's to fuck us.
Frankly, they
should all be sacked
'cause I've loved
Dick's my entire life.
But not any more and that's
hard for me to swallow.
Opposers, are there any
three words more exciting
than click and subscribe?
Yes, Hillary shot Lincoln.
Subscribe now and
find out the truth
they don't want you to know.
And by they I mean losers
looking for YouTube handouts
without clicking subscribe.
Do it.